Speaker 1: So yesterday we learned about this
incredible situation in which Mypillow founder
Mike Lindell, also known as Mike Pillow or
just Pillow?
We're doing a.
Speaker 2: Class action lawsuit against all
machines.
Speaker 1: That guy?
Yeah.
He had his phone seized by the FBI while at
a Hardee's drive thru.
We now have the search warrant that was presented
to Pillow.
And the search warrant exposes that this guy
is potentially in extremely serious trouble.
Newsweek has it in an article called Read
FBI is Mike Lindell Search Warrant Items To
Be Seized.
And if you scroll down the article, you get
to a section which is the list of everything
to be seized.
Check this out.
So, of course, it says the physical cellular
telephone assigned to pillow, which they got
all records and information on the Lindell
cell phone that constitute fruit's evidence
or instrumentalities of violations of identity
theft, intentional damage to a protected computer,
conspiracy to cufflink identity theft.
And on and on and on.
And it lists a number of different people.
But that is where it really gets very interesting
when you look at the specifics.
So it's a seizure of records and information
relating to damage to dominion voting systems.
There may be crimes here in having damaged
voting machines.
The guy saying he's investigating the voting
machines may have damaged voting machines,
records and information relating to bias on
a Dominion voting system machine.
Records and information relating to the attachment
of any peripheral to a dominion voting system
machine.
Records and information relating to any optical
disk drive.
So a lot of dominion voting machine stuff.
Okay, you then go further and you start to
see all records and information relating to
Cronin James Hayes.
CONAN James Hayes use of another person's
name, photograph, credentials or identifying
information or documents.
Who is CONAN James Hayes?
This is one of these guys who has spearheaded
election disinformation, was involved in the
Arizona so-called audit and seems to be wrapped
up in the pillow stuff with the machines.
And it all stinks to high heaven.
And there's possible identity theft here as
well.
Another really interesting item is item M
evidence of who used, owned or controlled
the Lindell cell phone at the time things
described in the warrant were created, edited
or deleted.
So this now it's very clear that the FBI is
also concerned with destruction of evidence.
Potentially here are evidence of software
that would allow others to control the Lindell
cell phone.
Evidence of the attachment to the Lindell
cell phone of other storage devices and on
and on and on.
This is extraordinarily detailed and I know
many people will say any time the FBI seizes
a phone, they have a whole bunch of these
different things.
They're fair.
But these are very specific provisions and
items, elements, for lack of a better term,
that relate to what Mike Pillow was up to.
And so there's clearly a concern about deleted
evidence.
The subpoena includes that.
And just think, if Trump and Pillow had just
stuck with, you know, their respective bailiwick,
which for Trump was, you know, I don't know,
real estate stuff and for pillow was selling
pillows.
They would both probably be better off right
now, certainly legally.
And the United States of America would be
dramatically better off.
We will see what happens next.
And by the way, this seizure has completely
triggered Mike Pillow, but we'll talk about
that more on tomorrow's program.
Guys in trouble, though.
Guys seems to be
in serious trouble.